there's
no way a venus fly trap can catch this
quick little wasp
or is there oh oh be careful don't get
too clo don't touch the oh
boy yep well there it is
the venus flytrap has long been the
stuff of sci-fi lore
it's green it's toothy and it's
carnivorous
it looks like an angler fish in plant
form and luckily for you
it doesn't eat humans who aren't on
broadway
the venus flytrap has a refined palette
well it's refined for a carnivorous
plant so what kind of creatures does it
eat
how does it eat them and why is this
plant carnivorous
in 1875 charles darwin wrote that the
venus fly trap is one of the most
wonderful plants in the world and if you
take one look at this thing's bright
green mandibles
it's easy to see why he thought that
this isn't an
average plant its exterior is a vivid
parakeet green
and its inside leaves are a deep blood
red
like a tongue but what's really crazy
about these plants is the way they eat
each trap is two hinged leaves that
produce sweet nectar to attract bugs
you probably think that's pretty
standard for a plant
but around each leaf is a series of
small tooth-like bristles
that interlock when the hinge snaps shut
the trap also has three short stiff and
extremely sensitive trichomes
or hairs and when something touches its
trichomes
a venus flytrap will definitely notice
but this sneaky plant won't shut its
trap right away
this avoids wasting energy on a
lackluster meal like dirt
leaves or tiny bugs but when something
juicier is on the menu like a slug
the hairs will bend multiple times
causing the mouth like leaves to snap
shut
in less than a second this keeps the
prey
and digestive juices inside while
keeping harmful bacteria out
however if the trap mistakenly closes on
a pebble or leaf
it will reopen in about 12 hours to spit
it out
the plant's movement in response to
being touched is called
thigma nasty and let me tell you
something it does get nasty
an average average-sized venus flytrap's
favorite foods are ants
beetles grasshoppers spiders flying
insects
and slugs but larger venus flytraps have
eaten frogs
i guess humans aren't the only ones who
think frog legs are a delicacy
after catching its prey the digestion
begins
and so do the horrors as the trap
squeezes tightly around its meal
glands located on the surface of the
leaves begin secreting a red
sap that helps break down the insect's
body
this gives the entire leaf a red
flower-like appearance
the trap also secretes an antiseptic
juice that stops the insect from
decaying
and digestive enzymes like the ones in
our stomachs
these juices dissolve the prey's soft
insides but not its tough exoskeleton
in five to twelve days the venus fly
trap finishes its meal
the leaves reabsorb the digestive fluids
the trap reopens
and the insects exoskeleton is usually
washed away by rain or blown away by the
wind
the reason these chomping plants are
carnivorous is due to the soil
venus flytraps eat insects to get
nitrogen and phosphorus that the soil
lacks
and despite rumors circulating on the
internet venus flytraps do not
like hamburger meat it gives them
indigestion and sometimes
kills the plants so if you have one
stick to feeding it bugs
or bug burgers while the venus fly trap
is no audrey ii from little shop of
horrors
it's still pretty sci-fi as far as
plants go and unfortunately
these remarkable plants are now a
vulnerable species due to
over-harvesting
habitat loss and lack of sunlight so if
you see a venus fly trap in the wild
it's okay to admire it but it's best to
leave it be
being carnivorous and having a sensitive
palate is what venus fly traps do
and that's what makes them crazy
creatures